la destrucción de un toyota blanco
seguido como objetivo por la
inteligencia estadounidense diez
integrantes de una familia e incluidos
siete niños murieron cuando un misil
detonó contra el vehículo en agosto
durante los últimos días de la caótica
evacuación estadounidense de kabul el
conductor del vehículo era un trabajador
humanitario
identificado por error como un militante
del estado islámico el gobierno
estadounidense ha ofrecido una
compensación económica no especificada a
sus familiares en un comunicado el
pentágono dijo que el ataque con dron
fue un error y que aquellos que murieron
fueron víctimas inocentes que no
formaban parte del estado de islámico de
corazón o una amenaza a las tropas
estadounidenses el ataque se produjo
mientras decenas de civiles intentaban
desesperadamente huir de la capital
afgana sólo tres días antes la situación
se había agravado cuando un atacante
suicida mató a decenas de personas en el
aeropuerto de kabul entre ellas a 13
integrantes de las tropas
estadounidenses unas tres semanas
después del ataque con dron
y admitió su error ofrezco mis profundas
condolencias a la familia de amigos de
aquellos que fueron asesinados en su
momento la familia dijo que una disculpa
no era suficiente modos no buscamos
justicia de organizaciones
internacionales de amnistía
internacional de todas las
organizaciones que defienden casos como
este el pentágono dijo que trabajaba con
el departamento de estado para dar
soporte a los familiares que quieran
instalarse en eeuu